[Musique]
nous sommes au jardin de montorgueil à
la bergerie nationale de rambouillet en
compagnie de frédérick dedieu bonjour
vous êtes le responsable des animations
à la bergerie
alors donc le public va pouvoir venir
gratuitement durant ce week-end ces deux
jours donc consacrée à l'ouverture de ce
jardin est ce que des visites sont
proposées
donc c'est effectivement le week-end
d'ouverture après deux ans de travaux
donc effectivement tout est gratuit ce
week-end il ya vraiment de quoi
s'occuper pour toute la famille des
animations pour les enfants les ados les
adultes et une belle programmation
culturelle de 14h45 à 18 heures avec
différents groupes
[Musique]
si je suis pieds nus c'est normal je me
trouve au jardin de montorgueil à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet ici un
parcours pieds nus de 500 mètres est
proposé nous allons retrouver le
responsable des animations de la
bergerie nationale
alors je me trouve sur le premier
élément de parcours la cause de cacao
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
peu justement ce parcours a
effectivement donc là c'est la première
case qui est donc composé de cause de
cacao et l'idée c'est de faire un
parcours qui dure qui peut durer une
demi-heure sur 500 m et de présenter
principalement tout ce qu'on peut
utiliser pour faire le paillage dans un
jardin donc
l'originalité c'est finalement de marché
dans ce qu'on peut utiliser pour faire
du jardinage écologique d'accord bah je
vais commencer
c'est parti c'est parti
à
alors là picotte peut-être oui ça picote
un peu alors là on est sûr ça s'appelle
de l'herbe à éléphant s'appelle de
miscanthus c'est ce qu'on ne peut
utiliser pour numériser les formes et
donc moins ici on s'en sert pour le
paillage attention ah ah ah c'est une
sensation plus à lui bien que les
copains de tout à l'heure alors la laine
de mouton donc lisez ces deux
effectivement de montrer au public tout
ce qu'on peut potentiellement utilisé
dans son jardin c'étaient des choses
très simples qu'on peut refaire dans son
jardin donc effectivement le paillage
mais aussi la valorisation vous allez
voir sur ce parcours il ya la
valorisation des branches des feuilles
des cailloux qui qui ont tous un rôle
finalement pour préserver la
biodiversité animale est aussi végétal
mais superbe on va continuer le parcours
alors oui donc ce parcours c'est jusqu'à
qu'on pourra y accéder
donc l'idée c'est d'ouvrir d'avril du
premier jour des vacances d'avril à la
fin des vacances d'octobre donc c'est
sur six mois forcément en hiver ça sera
peut-être un peu un peu un peu compliqué
et donc qu'on ouvre là finalement dans
quelques jours très bien il va merci
beaucoup
frédéric brieuc pour toute explication
merci à vous honte qui va moi je vais
continuer le parcours tout seul alors je
me trouve dans la partie bois ici
plusieurs obstacles à franchir dont la
planche à bascule
[Musique]
voilà j'ai fini le parcours j'ai marché
sur différentes textures le bois la
laine le sable c'était plutôt amusant
en tout cas si vous voulez comme moi
faire ce parcours rendez vous ce week
end